[Music]
it's time for me to jump for the first
time with the electric I'm so excited
I'll finally be able to fly in Minecraft
but I'm scared what if I fall
okay here we go cool that was awesome
alright let's give that another tribe
shall we what I what I do wrong do I
have to be in second mode it does that
why have I spent all this time trying to
get the OL I try and they doesn't work
fly wings fly by power what they're
sheep it doesn't work
step one jump from Blanc except you play
space key oh my god alright gamers here
we go I'm ready
oh god I'm scared okay yeah what's up
work yes Shane did you see that thing
that was awesome let's go a game gamers
now I am the dragon let's go first
person oh oh no oh no oh it'd be cool if
I can't launch myself somehow maybe I
can built like a catapult or something
here we go oh yeah virgin toad to
infinity and beyond what the tower is
easier to fly in second person are you
gonna finish that so I don't know if
this is true or not but I think you can
use rockets I've seen people do this
okay so I seen people use rockets to ply
with a light ray
that was awesome wait how does that work
how okay
what's up burgess aah oh my god yeah
[Music]
this is amazing is that greatest day in
my life
look at the meatball this is the
greatest thing that has ever happened to
me I can fly around the meatball damn
this means I can actually go like higher
places
oh god it's a little I need to work on
the lining
[Music]
yeah what's up
oh [ __ ] oh no okay
it needs I need some practice can I just
start from ground up no hmm see it would
be good to have some sort of launcher
minecraft just became ten times better
and I didn't know that was possible
did you guys see that wasn't that
awesome I won't beg to eat one of the
fruits see if he can teleport come on
finish it finish it okay so what if we
do this we put a slime it shoots us up
then we go with a electra span you ready
to see this what if I can shoot Sven
that'd be awesome
sent me that's even better it's more fun
if Sven despit ok gay
Sven just get on this line that's right
good boy that's it all right sleight all
right Sven you ready for your first ride
you can ride - ok he loves it
like crap okay
step aside my turn my turn my turn go go
go okay all right does that work with
the electric ow
it's okay I don't have ankles it's fine
I'll live
why does it not work do I need to go
higher
my ankles okay hey just work okay I'm
just not very good at the timing yeah
what's up Pam
okay so what if we can make it push you
site vertically as well
mindcrime greatest game when we can put
it on top of the meatball - so we get a
signal
excuse me Spence boyfriend why does that
not work oh okay and go alright timings
a little off all right no ticks no ticks
and go yeah you see that's man all right
that's fine
that's cool maybe make it higher dude
you've been chewing on that pork chop
for ages just finish it please
he's just teasing me with it now damn
Allah how you flying this is gonna be a
big 3 2 1 go
yeah alright one tank three two one go
term it ah come on
alright just misses
where do we make it one polar wait wait
don't let me I don't wanna sleep yet lip
sleep a little bit that can't see
anything but I think or a bit that slept
with me that's very sexy
alright one taller that should do the
trick
this became a redstone video I didn't
mean for this to happen
alright watch this okay I thought it
would work
why has no one told me how awesome slime
is hmm no one take water that took tea
on this misty three two one go why does
it just push me ah I have an idea
follow me spend the new left rule a
cannula what if I go on the rail and
then the rail activates piston would
activate a rail I have the momentum
speed of going forward then this shoots
me up boom we're flying epically super
fast look how excited fan is he's can't
hold his breath I felt like I should
have I should have tested this out
before I did it be here we go alright
well in theory it seems to be or don't
mock me spin is because it is a half
slab yeah it is I forgot half slabs
doesn't send signal boom now it should
work
alright gamers prepare for epicness
watch it celebrity' oh no I'm gonna run
you over Allah don't say a word
don't say a word all right I think I
know a fix I will liberate that prepare
for epicness don't say a word it's too
far down now
then can you get out of there should
that not same the signal okay now it
works
prepare for Double Trouble gamers now
you're gonna go thanks for doing the
engineering spend I really appreciate it
thank you okay Wow say that lap you
thought I couldn't do it huh
[Music]
that means Sven can do it too
which is the best parts van come here
spent can you seriously get out of there
or should I make it Lobby to do it can
dogs not climb ladders of course they
can why wouldn't they
all right well I bet that you do the
inspections I won't spend to ride this
one then trust me do you trust me of
course you did
Oh get in the bus get in the bus trust
me you're gonna let you're gonna love it
why is it so hard to get him in sometime
okay working come on buddy come on okay
okay okay all right
Zhen Shan Shan are you ready yes let's
go
well he 3/6 he went over he went over
OLAP for that that's amazing
Sven went over elaborate that was the
best thing I've ever seen
oh god now he's gonna pull lady sorry
said 360 overall Arista damn I don't
even I can't even do that Sven that's
all you know main okay so my my idea was
get the minecart no you can't go again I
hate actually I'm gonna go to sleep I'm
sick of creepers growing up my stuff oh
look speak of the devil
I hate you are you gonna finish that
pork chop keep working oh oh no no no no
come back
ah I mean the idea was to get them a
forwardable momentum right you get the
for momentum and then you know I can
jump out I jump out I go I fly up I jump
out I fly
got it this is what we're doing no one's
ever done this here we go okay so I
shift space rocket that's the client I'm
not moving
Wow yeah I don't need you guys laughing
at me you literally have it on your head
hula okay did I land on you I'm sorry I
didn't mean to do that
I thought you studied engineering Ola
what is this I have a new idea that is
even more epically why should I do it I
should do it here does they work on
water level to do the boat yeah he does
okay perfect and perfect I have you even
have the reset here man it's not your
time dope all right you want to go again
Suman there he goes No
Ola Britta what did you do it
you disappoint me Ola beta you're
supposed to be in charge of safety you
want to go fine but remember you're part
of the Safety Department so you can't
sue me if things go wrong okay oh my god
can you yard again and go I don't like
putting Jurgen in mine cars but are you
finishing matter
come on uragan you got to do it there we
go whoa it's so dumb wait what was I I
was supposed to use daylight right I
just love how it goes it back as well
it's so good let's put you back here
again we're about stop freaking more
working that's my life moto are you
gonna finish that
okay back to the ice chat ice challenge
we're gonna make the fastest launcher of
all time okay how do I do this we'll put
an absurd no help me virgin tone please
okay we'll put an observer here then
here we'll have a piston here slime
slime slime string redstone will a bit
that careful oh let me stop hey hey we
have a student's mother does that work
well all right well a bit I owe you what
are you doing in my house that's much
better
that's cévennes house how dare you damn
I forgot how cool this house looks never
use it all right it's over here
okay Sven are you ready to test the
speed you know what I have a bad feeling
but let's do it anyway
oh wow
get in the boat
okay attempt number two
look at that
and it works perfectly
almost God at that time almost got it
maximum speed we have built an airport
gamers it couldn't have been more
perfect
look at that Kia tower so beautiful
I fly as high as IKEA power goes whoa
whoa yeah can I fly through yes nail
bang oh yeah the people in here how are
you guys doing forgot about you guys
being internally in health okay we'll
have fun I guess that means I can also
make a bouncing pad okay I made a
bouncing pad for you guys so if I
connect this oh yeah all right who wants
to go ready for epic bounce bad can it
be quiet pink this is gonna be awesome
No
now
[Music]
ex-boyfriend
don't go near this is a deathtrap
No
[Music]
why what the shape why why did this
happen
suspense boyfriend was like a father to
me
I just wanted them to bounce
[Music]
there's something I need to tell you
I'm going far away from here
I don't deserve pants
[Music]
I don't deserve friends
what the Sheep keeps taking everyone I
love
[Music]
why what they're sheep why why I must
suffer I'm going away going far far away
where I can't hurt anyone
I'm sorry Jurgen
I'm sorry Bing you don't have to worry
about me I understand now that the only
way to keep you safe as if are much far
away as possible
[Music]